I remember having miss lecturing with
Sansa and waking up and being like this
is gone way too far
I think it is important to distinguish
because we all have our thing it might
be weird to someone but we all have
everything when I think of kinks I think
of the things that you know really get
you going that people wouldn't normally
think of or know about my more off the
spectrum cake is seeing men take care of
their children specifically like babies
maybe it's like my biological clock
being like he can take care of a child
when somebody says dirty things to me
like I'm very like I get super turned on
I do like my hair being pulled but it
has to be in the back of my head close
to my scalp
I like when when my lady puts like her
tongue in my ear I don't mean like like
licks it or kiss I like drown it like I
want my ear to feel like it's learning
how to swim again
I just really love a man in glasses when
I see men who wearing glasses and
they're walking down the street
confident walking tall I'm like this is
a man I need because we can be a power
duo will be a ties and we'll see the
whole world you know I'm really into
like hot candle life - light that's fire
right there so just be some like
powerful powerful rich oil tycoon in his
office and I burst in the door and he's
just like no I can't I have meetings and
I'm just like too bad and then I like
let down my hair and we just like go I
like the idea of you know writing love
notes to each other when the guy puts
his hand in your back pocket
consensually and I don't know just like
cute stuff like that
can you blame me I know that the whole
like glasses clinking it's a bit more
wholesome it's like not what people
thought what comes to mind when people
think Kings but that's the whole point
of Kings it's your preference the
bedroom should be a judgement free zone
and I think men should be able to
communicate woman what they want and
women should be able to convey what they
want I feel like it's weird for women to
talk about the kinks and the sexy things
that they're into because I feel like
they think that if they bring up these
freaky or nasty things that they're into
that they'll be looked at and judged
differently but it's a double standard I
mean where guys bring these up and we're
respected which I mean it's weird I
think times have changed for the better
I do miss some of the hopeless romantic
kind of just like courting stuff but at
the same time like I am so glad we're at
a place now where women can say what
they want you know consent is huge like
people know about it please know about
it I think that's what's so important
for people to remember is as weird as
your kink is don't overanalyze it to the
point that you think it's a judgment on
like yourself or the level of respect
you deserve I mean it's like really
healthy to draw that line it's really
just an individual liking what they like
like some people like to Pokemon some
people like licking toes like that
doesn't mean they're crazy or weird as
long as everything's consensual then
it's like you like what you like we all
have our fun little cakes
[Music]
you